wie weiter in der pandemie bund und
länder wollen dass alle schulen nach den
sommerferien wieder voll starten die
meisten großveranstaltungen bleiben bis
ende oktober verboten
neuer virus ausbruch in nrw in einem
schlachtbetrieb bei gütersloh gibt es
mehr als 650 infizierte kitas und
schulen im landkreis müssen wieder
schließen und siegesjubel ohne party
bayern münchen wird zum achten mal in
folge deutscher meister
die große feier fällt wegen der pandemie
aus
nachrichten ich das heute mit christian
sievers in allen hat sich dank dass sie
bei uns sind das schon mal vorweg sport
mit katja und gleich zwei deutschen
meistern unter anderem genannt
wir beginnen mit dem kampf gegen das
virus eine gemeinsame corona linie zu
finden für die kommenden monate
darum geht es dem ministerpräsidenten
der bundesländer heute bei einem zum
ersten mal wieder persönlichen gespräch
mit der bundeskanzlerin
fest steht spätestens nach den
sommerferien sollen wenn möglich alle
schulen wieder komplett staaten
großveranstaltungen wird es bis auf
einige ausnahmen bis mindestens ende
oktober in ganz deutschland nicht geben
und auch die masken pflicht soll weiter
gelten zumindest grundsätzlich britta
spiekermann berichtet in dieser
kombination hat man sich lange nicht
getroffen
die ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidentinnen im kanzleramt bei angela
merkel nach monaten der video und
telefonkonferenzen nun wieder alle
leibhaftig im großen kreis
wie geht es weiter mit corona jeder
machte zuletzt seien es bei den alltags
beschränkungen nrw eher locker bayern
eher streng jetzt wenn man sich
gemeinsam wieder abstimmen
zumindest in einigen punkten es bleibt
dabei dass bürgerinnen und bürger weiter
grundsätzlich ein mindestabstand von 1 5
meter einzuhalten haben und dass diese
maßnahme ergänzte durch einen mund nasen
bedeckung in bestimmten öffentlichen
bereichen erst mal auf unbestimmte zeit
bis es ein medikament gibt oder ein
impfstoff gefunden wurde
großveranstaltungen sollen bis ende
oktober verboten werden ausnahmen gibt
es dann wenn kontakte nachverfolgt
werden können und abstand und
hygienevorschriften eingehalten werden
für schulen und kitas soll es bald
wieder so etwas wie normalität geben
vorausgesetzt die infektionszahlen
bleiben niedrig wir haben vereinbart
dass wir nach den schulferien
für alle versuchen den regelbetrieb in
den schulen und kitas generell zu machen
das wird aber null gehen auch mit der
entsprechenden akzeptanz von bevölkerung
und auch beispielsweise der pädagogen
die uns ganz wichtig sind an diese
bilder wird man sich also gewöhnen
müssen maske und abstand im alltag
kanzlerin merkel mahnt weiterhin zur
vorsicht warnt vor rückschlägen die ganz
großen linien wurden heute abgestimmt
letztendlich handelt aber jedes land in
eigener verantwortung ein rückschlag im
kampf gegen korona im kreis gütersloh
dort müssen alle schulen und kitas bis
zu den sommerferien wieder zu machen
grund ist ein ausbruch des virus in
einem schlachtbetrieb der nimmt immer
größere ausmaße an mittlerweile sind
mehr als 650 mitarbeiter infiziert
thaddäus parade hat die details das
werbelogo dreht sich auf dem dach
ansonsten stehen in deutschlands größtem
schlachtbetrieb alle bänder stellt der
grund zahlreiche mitarbeiter der
fleischfabrik sind positiv auf das
corona virus getestet worden
der betrieb geschlossen ich mache das
damit es im kreis gut das so nicht zu
einem showdown kommt wir haben es hier
mit einem ereignis zu tun auf einem
bestimmten betriebsgelände bei einer
bestimmten firma und wir glauben es
verantworten zu können dass es nicht zu
einem showdown im kreis gütersloh kommen
muss schon seit wochen steht die
fleischindustrie im verdacht durch
minderwertige arbeitsbedingungen und
masse unterkünfte ihrer mitarbeiter
corona infektionsherde zu begünstigen
hoeneß wies solche vorwürfe stets von
sich wollte mit eigenen tests und
größeren wohneinheiten das
infektionsrisiko minimieren vergebens
wir können uns nur für diese situation
entschuldigen denn wir haben in den
vergangenen vier monaten alle maßnahmen
die die in abstimmung der behörde
ergriffen haben
vollzogen nicht die arbeitsbedingungen
sondern der wegfall der quarantäne
regeln bei der einreise aus osteuropa
sein problem vermutet der nordrhein
westfälische ministerpräsident
er sagt darüber überhaupt nichts aus
weil rumänen und bulgaren da eingereist
sind und da der virus herkommt das wird
überall passieren das ist natürlich
schon ein starkes stück jetzt den
menschen die die sich jetzt infiziert
haben die diese extrem harte arbeit
machen jetzt auch noch die schuld
zuzuschieben
einen erneuten kompletten locker und für
die region hat der kreis gütersloh
vorerst nicht geplant alle schulen und
kitas aber werden vorsorglich bis zu den
sommerferien wieder geschlossen
nachfrage noch bei heiko rahmens live in
gütersloh und heiko wieder einen
schlachtbetrieb wie konnte es jetzt in
diesem konkreten fall wieder dazu kommen
ja diese frage stellen sich hier alle
tönnies sagt es kann damit zu tun haben
dass die beschäftigten die hier arbeiten
die aus bulgari aus bulgarien aus
rumänien stammen in den vergangenen
tagen in ihre heimatländer gefahren sind
nach dem langen lockdown wollten sie
ihre familien wieder treffen und dann
vielleicht das virus mit hierhin
gebracht haben und hier in diesem
betrieb verbreitet haben
das ist allerdings nur die theorie von
tönnies klar ist die arbeitsbedingungen
hier sind nicht optimal die menschen
arbeiten eng an eng die räume sind sehr
niedrig temperiert das sind alles
voraussetzungen die dazu beitragen dass
sich das virus ideal verbreiten kann
ob das jetzt wirklich die ursache war
das wissen wir noch nicht das müssen die
behörden ermitteln und da müssen wir uns
einfach noch ein wenig gedulden korans
zdf gütersloh herzlichen dank solche
lokalen ausbrüche machen natürlich
schlagzeilen schaut man aber auf das
ganze land dann bleibt die zahl der
neuinfektionen insgesamt weiter auf
niedrigem niveau
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage steckten sich 250 menschen täglich
neu mit dem corona virus an
dieser wert hat sich leicht erhöht
angefangen hat die korona pandemie in
china und da wächst gerade die angst vor
einer zweiten welle vor einem neuen
großen ausbruch vor allem in der
millionen metropole peking viele wochen
lang wurden fast gar keine
neuinfektionen gemeldet jetzt haben sich
nach offiziellen angaben mehr als 130
menschen in wenigen tagen angesteckt
immer mehr stadtviertel werden
abgeriegelt hunderte flüge wieder
gestrichen
aus peking
andy schöneborn auf pekings straßen gibt
es überall verteilt kleine illegale
straßenverkäufer es sind die händler die
ihre ware nicht mehr auf den großen
märkten verkaufen können
denn diesen geschlossen auch das ist
china zu zeiten von corona die angst vor
dem virus ist groß doch überleben müssen
die menschen auch wirtschaftlich
die wirtschaftlichen verluste sind hoch
die standmiete hat uns der markt nicht
erlassen
dabei haben wir schon miete für vier
monate bezahlt 500 euro pro monat sind
es letzten samstag wurde der großmarkt
im südwesten der stadt geschlossen
mehr als 30 wohnviertel sind
mittlerweile abgeriegelt auf allen
märkten der stadt werden wieder massive
kontrollen durchgeführt
seit bekanntwerden der offiziellen neuen
infektionszahlen berichtet das
staatsfernsehen von corona tests die in
massen durchgeführt werden mehr als
350.000 bisher perfekt organisiert
offiziell dürfen wir dort nicht drehen
unsere aufnahmen mit handy videos zeigen
wie die menschen dicht an dicht auf ihre
tests warten
wie groß die verunsicherung und die
angst vor einer möglichen zweiten welle
ist es daran zu sehen wie leer die
straßen sind es ist pflicht wieder
mundschutz zu tragen
vor allen dingen haben die menschen aber
angst vor einem lock down der die
wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen könnten
enorm sein
alle überregionalen busse dürfen seit
heute peking nicht mehr verlassen
teile der stadt sind weggesperrt der
kampf gegen das virus ist auch in peking
noch nicht zu ende
dem virus etwas entgegensetzen in
deutschland soll das ja unter anderem
die neue waren app der bundesregierung
seit gestern auf dem markt ist sie
bislang mehr als acht millionen mal
heruntergeladen worden
und auch beim langfristigen kampf gegen
korona tut sich etwas das unternehmen
chorwerk aus tübingen darf ab jetzt
einen möglichen impfstoff an gesunden
freiwilligen testen erste ergebnisse ob
er wirkt und verträglich ist könnte es
dann ab september geben zulassung
frühestens anfang nächsten jahres ihr
werk ist neben bayern tag die zweite
deutsche firma die ihren impfstoff
klinisch testen lassen darf unser
nächstes thema die
nato-verteidigungsminister haben viel zu
besprechen
eigentlich wollten sie ein signal der
geschlossenheit in richtung russland
senden aber um die geschlossenheit steht
es in der ära trump nicht allzu gut der
us-präsident hatte ja gerade einen
teilabzug von truppen aus deutschland
gekündigt und die regierung in berlin
scharf kritisiert deutschland zahle zu
wenig in die nato kasse aus brüssel
stefan leifert wäre dies ein physisches
treffen in brüssel gewesen hätten sie
hier aufgeregt die köpfe
zusammengesteckt bei der nato war
niemand vorgewarnt trump hat mit seiner
abzugs ankündigung alle überrascht mehr
klarheit über die us-pläne herrscht nach
der video schalte der
verteidigungsminister aber noch immer
nicht
es gibt immer noch keine endgültige
entscheidung darüber wann und wie die us
pläne umgesetzt werden
natürlich geht die us präsenz in europa
über deutschland hinaus aber deutschland
hat historisch und aktuell immer eine
sehr bedeutende us präsenz gehabt
aus zorn über deutschlands angeblich zu
niedrige verteidigungsausgaben hatte der
us-präsident angekündigt 9500 der über
34.000 soldaten aus deutschland
abzuziehen und nach polen zu verlegen
in berlin herrscht vorsichtig gesagt
befremden die nato ist keine
handelsorganisation und sicherheit ist
keine ware die nato gründet sich auf
solidarität und auch vertrauen und sie
gründet sich auf gemeinsame werte und
auf gemeinsame interessen und wir haben
heute nach wie vor
diese gemeinsame interessen vielleicht
sogar noch mehr als vorher
in der nato hoffen sie insgeheim dass
sich trump drohung im us wahlkampf
wieder verliert trump hat mit seinem
alleingang mächtig unruhe ins bündnis
gebracht bei der nato fürchten sie dass
es nicht der letzte war
je mehr trump seine wiederwahl gefährdet
sieht so die sorge
desto gefährlicher wird der fluss
bündnis sagt stefan leifert in brüssel
auch wenn es seit tagen immer mal wieder
regnet es ist immer noch viel zu trocken
in deutschland an bilder wie diese von
ausgetrockneten feldern haben wir uns in
den letzten jahren ja fast schon gewöhnt
aber nicht nur in der landwirtschaft
fehlt wasser in den wäldern sterben
bäume heute ist der welttag zur
bekämpfung der wüstenbildung vor jahren
schien der uns so gar nicht zu betreffen
aber das hat sich geändert volker
angriff
es könnte zum dritten mal in folge ein
dürres sommer werden die böden trocknen
aus immer schwieriger die situation auf
deutschlands äckern für bauern wie
sebastian glaser im hessischen nordrhein
existenzbedrohend wir betrieben ein jahr
unter umständen durchhalten zwei oder
gar drei jahre ist man sich noch nicht
schaffbar das kriegt man nicht hin der
dürre monitor des helmholtz zentrums für
umweltforschung zeigt auch für den juni
2020 keine besserung die rote markierung
signalisiert vor allem im osten und
süden deutschlands herrscht eine
außergewöhnliche dürre erregung der
miniatur zurück bis 1951
man muss ja ganz nicht dann sagen so
eine langanhaltende dürre wäre das im
gesamten boden seit 2008 zehn
mittlerweile in deutschland haben hatte
so vorher nicht gegeben
auch der wald leidet braune nadeln
abgeworfene blätter lichte kronen folgen
eines viel zu trockenen bodens unsere
wälder sie müssen sich verändern hin zu
mehr lauf- und mischwald die absehbaren
sommergewitter mit teils heftigen
regengüssen helfen nicht bei diesen
heftigen gewitter niederschlägen geht
weniger wasser in den boden rein und es
läuft mit meerwasser oberflächlich ab
über den sommer ist es wo man heute
tatsächlich mehrere monate mit
überdurchschnittlichen niederschlag um
in den gesamten boden wie das so viel
wasser rein zu bekommen das auch in den
wäldern der zustand wieder deutlich
besser wird
keine gute perspektive also für die
wälder wie geht es weiter
dürren werden ein häufiges problem seien
auch eine wüstenbildung wird es in
deutschland so nicht geben
deutschland wüsten frei immerhin doch
die folgen des klimawandels werden wir
weiterhin erleben
viel zu trocken nicht nur bei uns
weltweit ist das ein riesenproblem wie
ganze landschaften austrocknen
eine ausführliche story dazu mit vielen
beispielen gibt es in unserer zdf heute
ab heute siebzehnter juni das ist ein
besonderes datum gerade für alle
ostdeutschen hunderttausende menschen
gingen vor 67 jahren in der ddr für
freiheit auf die straße als
volksaufstand ging das in die geschichte
an
in mehreren städten wurde daran mit
grenzen erinnert wegen corona ohne reden
und nur mit wenigen geladenen gästen
damals hatte sich der aufstand aus
spontanen streiks entwickelt mit panzern
schlug die sowjetarmee den protest
blutig nieder mindestens 55 menschen
wurden getötet und rund 10.000 kamen ins
gefängnis
als kind hatte matthias in armut und
hunger selbst erlebt zur frankfurter
buchmesse im herbst wird der 86 jährige
indische wirtschaftswissenschaftler und
philosoph mit dem friedenspreis des
deutschen buchhandels ausgezeichnet
sein großes thema ist die soziale
gerechtigkeit und die frage wie
ungleichheit bekämpft werden kann
1998 bekam matthias senn als erster
asiate den wirtschaftsnobelpreis und
jetzt zwei nachrichten auch in eigener
sache
im kommenden jahr könnte der
rundfunkbeitrag steigen
die ministerpräsidenten haben sich
geeinigt dass der monatliche beitrag ab
januar um 86 cent angehoben werden soll
auf dann 18 eur 36 die erhöhung kommt
allerdings nur wenn auch noch alle
landtage zustimmen
dazu jetzt die vorsitzende der
rundfunkkommission der länder malu
dreyer ja alle spüren in der korona
krise noch einmal wie wichtig unsere
medien sind und wir sind wirklich froh
dass wir das duales system haben
natürlich können medien nur freien